cast IRL will be live in Miami with
Patrick Bet David Donald Trump Jr Matt
Gates and Luke gradkowski join us there
get your tickets by clicking the link in
the description below or by going to
timcast.com it's interesting you say you
know the U.S thinks it strategically
helps us to be funding this war or
whatever but I would kind of make a
counter argument to that which is in
many ways we pushed Russia and Ukraine
into the spot you kind of look at the
history of the uh the Minx Accords and
stuff over the years you know the United
States has stepped in repeatedly and
told Ukraine don't negotiate with Russia
you know they kept Fanning the Flames of
this but then what has happened now as a
consequence of that is Russia now in the
moment may look kind of stupid hey look
their Invasion isn't going so well
but what's long term what's long-term
happening is Russia is being back now
into the corner of China and you know
they're all together now and meeting and
there's an alliance there it's obviously
forming people say oh that's inevitable
because they're both authoritarians
that's not true at all when you look at
the history of Russia and China there's
a reason why they've actually been a
little bit more isolated and Putin's
been nervous about going into China's
hands even when they were both
communist right the Soviet Union and
Malice China didn't even get along
um and I think Putin's been in this
position the past few decades where he's
not sure do I want to be Western or
Eastern tries to play Both Sides we
could have potentially if not an ally at
least neutralized a very strong threat
in having uh Russia not on the side of
China and isolating China but instead
what we've done through the whole course
of basically in many ways I would argue
inciting this war and definitely feeling
the Flames of it is now long term we
have a very powerful axis that we
constructed ourselves and now we're
gonna have to fight at once and maybe
they want it yeah maybe they want it
they create they create a problem yeah
that gives them a crisis that they can
use to exploit and Implement new
policies plans but I'm gonna just err on
the side of stupidity over malice on
this one I agree I think that the
argument that a weak Russia makes a
strong U.S is flawed and I would argue
with any defense contract or any anyone
in the administration anyone wants to
talk because a a weakened Russia becomes
a desperate Russia in a desperate Russia
has nuclear weapons that's not good for
American sovereignty a strong Russia has
nuclear weapons too though unless we are
not concerned with their nuclear weapons
for some reason maybe yeah that's true
and also we think Russia seeks allies
elsewhere and we don't want that doesn't
make us strong America and this is a
little bit of an unsecurity I heard that
uh musk is Contracting with the feds to
build star Shield or something which is
essentially the Iron Dome in the U.S
starshield I don't know if this is true
I I it's it's a rumor that I heard so I
don't I don't have any information on it
I was from a year ago
so SpaceX unveils star Shield a military
variation of starlink satellites secure
satellite networks digital Iron Dome
okay so that's so then this is just an
internet oh it's a security system well
it says security does that mean like
laser defense well I imagine it could be
if you've got multiple satellites that
are it's just it's just Starling for the
government okay it's a it's an isolated
Network so that it protects the
government
to do Defending Your satellites I mean
in the near future things up there that
can space I mean the thing is if you can
be strong if you can get a a you know a
constellation of satellites similar to
starlink then you can identify you know
uh missiles that are that are being shot
from anywhere in the world you can pick
them up as they're they're getting off
the ground and the idea is hopefully you
can shoot them down before they get over
the us if you I mean they have big
lasers that they put in c5as that can
shoot down missiles and so if you can
get them before they actually try to
deliver their mervs or whatever that
might be that might be part of it so I
mean this is and low low orbit satellite
is the vehicle for these laser
interception systems so but how would
they collect and store enough power even
with satellite to store enough power for
a directed energy weapon is it's it's
it's insane it's going to be like years
of charging up I imagine that they can
even hold it I imagine that they're just
to identify and and notify the the US
that there is some kind of ground level
thing going on yeah when it takes off
and then like I said you put a C5 in the
air with a big uh chemical laser in it
and make you know because you can
scramble if it's got 30 minutes you can
scramble the C5 in 10 if you have them
on standby get them in the air and get
them before they're I kind of feel like
they'd probably just go the traditional
Iron Dome or Thad method which is
launching rockets and Rockets should be
or could be yeah I mean maybe lasers are
the last resort but the range on them is
not going to be strong enough the
original lasers yeah I mean by the time
there's enough power in the laser at
least based on what we understand the
nuke is already in a very damaging
radius of whatever the target is but if
they have these laser systems you know
strategically placed far outside of
Civilian or military areas okay then
perhaps but if we're talking about a
Merv from Russia which is going to be in
the stratosphere
I don't know man is that a plane to
intercept it and hope that the laser
mounted on you know that's what I think
it is I know that they do they they have
tested uh
lasers on you know mounted in big cargo
planes because they're they're massive
and they take up a lot of space and
they're chem they're chemical lasers if
I understand correctly
um but again I'm I'm not an expert at
all so this is this is me relating what
I've read
um so but it you know I imagine that
that would make you know Russia less of
a threat but I still don't think that uh
I wouldn't trust it anyway yeah no well
I mean it's world war three you're gonna
count on your survival hey the
government built some lasers
um I don't think it would happen hosted
payloads it says on its website SpaceX
says star Shield will have an initial
focus on three areas imagery
Communications and quote hosted payloads
third of which effectively offers
government customers the company's
satellite bus the body of the spacecraft
as a flexible platform hmm But what is
that what does that mean like it's going
to carry something payload sounds like a
virus
a payload is is usually some kind of
weapon you know if you're talking about
the payload on a nuclear weapon that's
the that's the the Warhead would be the
payload so I don't know exactly what hey
look if the U.S this does real low orbit
ion cannon I'm not complaining great
this those are my actually but it's
funny this does remind me a lot of the
Star Wars stuff in the 1980s so I wonder
if this is actually a serious idea or
just you know bluffing like it was in
the 80s obviously with Reagan I don't
know he he had some for people and I'm
not familiar you had some plan some
crazy plan with Blazers whatever it is
yeah to shoot down Russian nukes and the
whole thing was blunder uh Bluff but the
point of it I guess intuitively was what
I thought it was just that they didn't
have the technology at the time
well I think part of the reason they
talked it up that way was because they
wanted to get the Soviet Union to you
know run up their military budget and
basically blow up yeah now they have
hypersonically the Hypersonic Weaponry I
don't know enough about it it's actually
slower it's slower than regular nakano
oh why is it why is it touted is uh
indefensible then they're like we can't
shoot down our Hypersonic stuff because
they're talking about missiles where
it's an ICBM actually goes into orbit
and to get into orbit it's 20 000 miles
an hour is that what you have to is how
fast you have to go something like that
to break Earth orbit whereas Hypersonic
would be you know uh what's the speed of
sound is 750 miles an hour it's fine I
think they travel five times speed of
sound it has something to do with uh
Hypersonic missiles travel low closer to
the Earth and are harder to uh track and
respond to so with um icbms they go up
they go high they go fast but the higher
it goes with the curvature of the Earth
the the more the more range we have for
detecting them whereas hypersonics are
low and slow the escape velocity of
Earth is 33 times the speed of sound so
the a uh a Hypersonic missile is
actually significantly slower than an
ICBM
okay
but yeah Hypersonic missiles so this is
uh check it out here you go Yep this is
from a couple days ago this is amazing
Hypersonic missile weapons are super
fast so you can see ballistic missiles
Hypersonic and Crews Hypersonic stays
low and is outside radar detection
before and then it's too late yeah this
is the US Navy is developing directed
Energy Systems as a potential defense
against Hypersonic it's a cool graphic
and uh that's military it's basically
aerospace.com talks about the Navy's
laser weapon defense and if they're
talking about laser weapon defense
openly then they've probably got some
nasty laser weapon defense Star Wars
Bluff like you're saying earlier this is
basically what my point was you can see
right here in the graphic uh they don't
show the the graphic that I want I
watched a while ago about this shows the
curvature of the earth and explains why
radar detection is limited and it's
because as the Earth curves the radar
goes out and so there's certain areas
where you're not going to see anything
at the ground level and the hypersonics
track closer to the ground and then slam
to the Target before you realize it the
Boeing Yale 1 Airborne laser tested uh
weapon system was a megawatt class
chemical oxygen iodine laser mounted
inside a modified military Boeing 747
400 f it was designed as a missile
defense system to destroy tactical
ballistic missiles while in boost phase
I don't know if it's actually
so apparently these hypersonics go 20
times the speed of sound so maybe wow so
they could break anywhere on the earth
in a matter of hours yeah and it was in
less than an hour holy crap in less than
one hour
man that's wild
you know one day there's going to be
like some prominent personality who's
leading the charge against war or
something and then before anyone even
realizes that there's gonna be a crater
where his house used to be and it's okay
we have no idea what happened no one
could see it I mean look Russia and it's
pretty clear that Russia shot down that
uh rosney guy they shut down yeah they
shot down his plane so I I imagine that
kind of technology in the hands of a you
know regime like Russia or you know some
other uh less than Democratic uh regime
would do just that smoke someone that is
irritating them without looking 16 year
olds but what if what if star Shield
is actually radar detection
from space to track hypersonics that's
what I imagine so take a look at this
right they're showing right here in this
graphic that the signal the wave is
coming from the ground and going up and
the radar can't detect Beyond this uh
this this you know angle what if you had
a radar from space then you'd have the
inverse then it would be able to see
everything happening
like a spider web anything that comes in
you can pinpoint it with thousands of
satellites up there you know exactly
where it is now you've got space radar
in which case it's Hypersonic you can
track
I like how the cruise missile just
doesn't make it anywhere it's just like
14 minutes it barely when was the cruise
missile invented how long ago was that
oh goodness I don't know I wonder I
wonder if that was uh that's probably
still after uh rocketry I mean V2 70s
70s I imagine because they they were
using cruise missile Cruise misses were
the first thing I remember seeing when
in the first Iraq War I was 15 years old
and like they'd started shoving cruise
missiles down Saddam Hussein's neck and
and it was it was impressive you know as
a kid to be like whoa that's actually
yeah you know the missile that Trump
dropped while he was President the
mother of all Moab it was that a cruise
missile no that's a that is a gravity
bomb they call it it's a thermobaric
bomb so it actually when it hits the
ground or when it when it detonates
first it shoots out a bunch of uh gas
that blows up oh interesting nights the
gas it looks like the first cruise
missile was invented during World War
One by the Americans but it wasn't used
and during the interwar period not many
people were working on but Germany went
hard on on the rockets and I could be
wrong about the way that it works I
could be thinking of a different thing
sure I know the Moab is Big it was it's
the biggest munition that is not a
nuclear weapon And to clarify a cruise
missile specifically is a missile that's
that's uh supposed to hit a Target on
land that's the point of it that's why
they call it a cruise missile I guess
G2 the Vengeance weapon
the venge v stands for vengeance the V2
rocket it's the
virgalton swap
whereas with the V2s were the ones where
the British Pilots had to like tip them
out of the way right am I getting that
one right it was a Nazi I know that yeah
yeah because they weren't that fast but
it was a completely new technology I
don't know you mean like with their
plane so they have to fly alongside it
and then you tip it with your wing and
it's just enough to Veer it out off its
course yeah yeah no it wasn't really
that effective from what I hear they
just had a lot of them and no one else
did they poured their research and
development into the video that was that
was part of Hitler's problem is he
always wanted to focus on very
sci-fi-esque at the time futuristic
ideas instead of what was practical and
this was one of them you know it just it
didn't do the damage to London and
England that was worth all the money
they put into it yeah they want to just
rock it England all day every day and
then the nukes got invented so
everyone's saying V1 is the the missile
that I'm talking about it's the
predecessor to the V2 is the one the
British would just tip out of the way
with their own planes have you seen I
think the whole three then was the giant
gun right the Giant Cannon and that went
from several miles and like I said it's
a safe oh wow it's a giant gun you talk
about the windows on a rail yeah okay
yeah and didn't they just blow it up or
whatever you can just bomb it
if you can in the German super gun
I've never heard of it either they had
this big cannon that was
ridiculously big it had to be moved on
Rail and and it was not practical
anything that you have to that has to be
like on rail to move that's completely
impractical and it's easy to bomb that's
easy to destroy yeah yeah before like
World War One when they just had hot air
balloons and stuff they were extremely
effective artillery on rail but now with
air support it's they're just targets
yeah I mean not just targets but they're
easily targetable from space and you
know I talk with a lot of confidence
about military Tech I'm not a military
guy this one put that out there I I
defer to anyone with combat experience
or that's an expert on the Weaponry
because I love hearing about this stuff
it's crazy
2754 civilians killed in London by V2
attacks and 6523 injured but see that's
not really a lot when you consider the
total death during the war and the
amount of money that went into that
versus the return two people per Rockets
it's uh right that's not a really good
investment at all they'd be better off
putting rocks on blimps just having the
Rocks fall I mean you're you're right
and we say that demanded this with bombs
yeah if you think about think about the
uh the amount of money that was spent in
Iraq like every time that they shot a
Hellfire at like a goat herder you know
you because they do because it would
just be some random dude that got paid
you know whatever 100 bucks or whatever
to go up on the hill and with his old
1910 Springfield rifle or whatever take
a couple pot shots at the at the base
because the point is to just harass the
Americans and the Americans reply was
calling the helicopters and they just
started lighting up the whole Hillside
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8 pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time